I will come to this segment first what
would you like to hear a rap about
Martians cool
what yes please you're so polite you
look you look like you could work at
SpaceX or something where are you from
you're from Tucson oh no amendment you
know okay that's fine and then you know
kind of work wise but what what is it
about Martians that intrigues you mostly
there aren't any I didn't even think
about antennae yeah if you picture a
Martian do you guys picturing antenna on
their head no he's thinking of
caterpillars but I okay Martian and 10i
I like that guys over here on this
little wedge what you want to hear rap
about you're not on that side and it's
also a food so shut up what I'm gonna
not follow instructions in many
different ways Chris guys over here dogs
being left alone at home okay I mean
technically it violates the animals rule
but then it's made more interesting a
you is that what you're worried about at
the moment yeah what's your dog called
okay what's your favorite one called
okay that was very quick
it's just Rosie what's the other one
called [ __ ] dog Oh something different
so Rosie the Rottweiler that is such a
lovely kind of delicate name for such a
vicious beast okay Rosie the Rottweiler
being left at home Martians and they're
on 10a and people at the back of the
room
what was that hotbox is that when you
smoke a marijuana cigarette in your
vehicle someone over there said no but
then someone over here went he'll year
so I'm gonna assume that is what it
means because I think all of you could
say no and I would still go with the man
who said oh yeah
oh my heart bugs is joint right now
right so we have hotbox Rosie the
Rottweiler being left at home Martian
antennae let's come to this side of this
bit of the room what one second you guys
seem really I'm gonna come to you guys
in a moment I just feel like I should
keep you waiting it's very funny for me
just how people going oh oh please me
please me guys over here why'd y'all
wrap up mmm you said that with a kind of
jovial lil twitch I feel that phrase has
never been said in no-one's ever is like
oh why you looking so miserable I have a
urinary tract infection
it's okay call urinary tract infection
otherwise known as a UTI men we we don't
get them because we're very fortunate
with our genitalia so so the people who
had that you you are really making a
gesture and I dressed magnificently no
it's really wonderful this is this is
your real clothes yes you're doing high
tea okay cool I mean that guy did a
height even in a different way over
there
again he said hell yeah so what would
you like a suggestion about well why
would you like suggest for the round
this is the final one so it better be
good okay cool I feel like it was
improved by three people saying it in
different voices high tea for those who
they don't know how high tea is a
British tradition we're at around 3 p.m.
we'll settle down with some scones some
which like biscuits but not savory with
a pot of tea and some little kind of
things you make cucumber sandwiches yeah
right because cucumber sandwiches people
ask why were they invented it's because
the British high-class wanted to show
off that they could eat food that had no
nutritional value look look how rich we
are we don't even care that there's a
famine we could still eat this raw
normal so eating was like you know
conspicuous concerted an anthropology
degree I'm very happy I got to use it
right then my parents are like use your
degree I'm like I did it mum it's great
so the suggestions we have were Martians
in their antennae rose rose a the
Rottweiler being left at home hotbox
a urinary tract infection
and high tea what aspect of high tea G
did you enjoy the most the tea itself
what blend do you go for English
breakfast yeah but how do you blend your
English breakfast with Earl Grey well
then it ceases to be an English
breakfast what you've done there is you
blended black tea with bergamot yeah why
are you surprised that I know what that
is usually an ass am as well right okay
cool that's enough teacher this lovely
people of the comedy magic club hello a
treat for you guys a little thing called
a freestyle rap there's a rap made up on
the spot based in Italian those
suggestions never to be seen again it's
never been seen before and don't worry
it won't be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
British boy could be hello sorry to
interrupt the video it's me Chris if I
was drawn by one of the artists from
Bob's Burgers I wanted to let you know
that I am going on tour if you live in
or near any of these cities or these
cities then please do come and see my
live show I can't wait to hear your
suggestions my raps shouted out in
person tickets are on sale now the link
is in the description or click the card
in the top right corner thank you for
watching and I will see you there that's
let's drop that beat my friend and have
some fun meal of the day
you all agree sit down and share with me
a nice trailer hiding maybe get China to
eat but I've gotta make sure that it's
hot before the water starts to pour
otherwise the leaves don't unfurl where
did you get from somewhere in the third
world
probably India or China bringing all
your family
never caused a shine once I get a bit of
white bread cutting off the crusts if
you leave them on the edge of the bread
I don't trust you I wanna make sure they
got cheese and maybe little bit of
cucumber yes please I will take a little
scone with a bit of strawberry jam when
it comes to high tea in England
everybody who feels on my team come
round and feast upon the tea with the
Queen Lizzy in a palace she's got a lot
of balance if you say the tea tastes bad
she pours malice on you getting angry
who's looking at you crafty like a
little fox hotbox in the back seat you
can see me what's the point I'm thinking
back then I'm smoking a joint at the
same time yeah you know it won't harm
your medicine no qualities inside the
marijuana I get the best grade coming
from the hydroponic I drink it in the
back on my dodge top of it the i-10
freeway 405 IV swerving so fast it's
hard to stay alive I'm following the
Grateful Dead in the tour bus the lure
on the state they abour us they don't
like that we drive in it leave leave it
doesn't my you can get the weed and get
it for free you don't need to bring your
own if you're hotbox ba get in
it's when you don't pass the droit
around the little rings you need to go
clockwise from the star in pass the
Dutchie to the left-hand side
what is a joint we are not aware of
these things yes it brings us all
together I feel all of the love I can
sense with antenna never seen the main
looking cartoon before with the parrot
and tonight this guy saw Marvin the
Martian from Looney Tunes he says cause
I've got antenna how do you not assume
looking like tiny little bugs on the
prowl
if I saw a Martian in real life out how
they've got the weird red skin and they
felt kind of annoyed that the asteroid
belt stops them getting through to
Jupiter like the wall but we Mexico in
here it's kind of a little thing I'll
say you again I made a nice comparison
to illegal aliens yeah we did you might
ask me why I feel kind of comfortable
yu-gi-oh I got the infection in my
urinary tract the doctor said please doc
I need them no thing to stop the porn on
my car he says usually these guys are
not the ones who receive the UTIs I just
went by and say I quote from my lady
I had a sexual intercourse lately and he
was like okay mr. Crist what are you
symptoms it burns when I piss
TM I know the little I'm gonna try what
a great thing working out of my mind
maybe get some cranberry help you wonder
why that's the juice that we use get it
on offer I'm going up to the bartender
order of vodka but then makes it the
juice from the tiny red berry how many
you tease in my life so many and if I
see the color coming out clearly it's
kind of like this song because Rosie
the truth when you leave the house you
go celebrate with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]